KARIM LAKHANI: Crowdsourcing is a
subset within open innovation, where
we rely on hundreds if not thousands of
people working in parallel sometimes,
competitively or collaboratively, to go
solve problems that we may care about.
Crowdsourcing basically burst
into the scene in the early 2000s
when we started to see
companies and platforms emerge
that relied on the wisdom of the crowd
to help us write Wikipedia articles.
To help us write software code.
And to even solve the
toughest science problems.
So crowdsourcing fits in within
this broader paradigm that ideas
reside outside of the company.
And the best ways for
a company to innovate
is to often go to the outside
world and bring it in.